[Música]
el enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad terminó una protesta de
cientos de personas a las afueras de una
base militar de Ciudad de México los
manifestantes pedían respuestas por los
43 estudiantes de Ayotzinapa
desaparecidos en 2014 en vísperas del
octavo aniversario de la tragedia
solo durante el mes de agosto la
deforestación en la amazonía brasileña
aumentó en un 80% respecto al mismo mes
del año pasado según datos del gobierno
la cifra se conocen acerca de una semana
de las elecciones presidenciales y en
las que la protección del medio ambiente
ha sido un tema fundamental de la
campaña electoral
América Latina también se unió a la
cerca de 450 manifestaciones en todo el
mundo con el objetivo de generar
conciencia sobre el cambio climático se
trata del movimiento frailes for Future
que tuvo movilizaciones en países como
México Argentina y chile
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en Francia 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en México cientos
de manifestantes se enfrentaron a las
fuerzas de seguridad frente a una base
militar en la capital del país durante
el plantón en protestas por la
desaparición de los 43 estudiantes de
Ayotzinapa y la falta de Claridad e
investigación de lo sucedido a pocos
días de que se celebre el octavo
aniversario de la tragedia las madres de
algunos de los desaparecidos también se
trasladaron a Ciudad de México para
exigir respuestas Marina sardina con los
detalles
pancartas con las consignas fue el
ejército o nos faltan 43 cientos de
estudiantes y familiares de los
estudiantes desaparecidos en Ayotzinapa
realizaron un plantón frente a una base
militar de México que terminó el
enfrentamientos entre la policía y los
manifestantes mientras las madres cuyos
hijos siguen desaparecidos cargaban
carteles con sus rostros es preocupante
decir que hasta el día de hoy no sabemos
nada de nuestros hijos y en los que nos
duele en lo más profundo de nuestro
corazón no saber a dónde está nuestros
hijos y es por eso que estamos aquí este
dejando familia nuestros hogares dejando
todo nuestro trabajo por venir aquí por
manifestarnos que queremos la verdad A
dónde está nuestros hijos no podemos
permitir más injusticias basta de
impunidad los manifestantes derribaron
las vallas se intentaron Acceder al
campo militar número uno de la capital
dejando al menos un uniformado herido
el 26 de septiembre se cumplen ocho años
de la tragedia motivo por el que
activistas y familiares están saliendo a
las calles para exigir respuestas a las
autoridades después de que la comisión
para la verdad señalar al mes pasado que
se trata de un crimen de estado con
autoridades de todos los niveles y el
mismo ejército implicados
[Música]
elementos del ejército hasta el momento
se han dictado órdenes de detención
contra más de 80 sospechosos entre ellos
militares policías y miembros de
carteles este viernes el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador prometió que
estos crímenes no quedarán impunes en
Ecuador el presidente Guillermo lasso
pidió la renuncia del ministro del
interior Patricio Carrillo por el manejo
que se le ha dado al caso de María Belén
Bernal la abogada que fue encontrada sin
vida en un cerro cercano de la escuela
superior de policía en el norte de quito
el último lugar al que ya acudió para
visitar a su pareja quien figura como
principal sospechoso y ahora se
encuentra prófugo lazo también dijo que
pedirá Las bajas de altos mandos
policiales y exige que en una semana se
ha capturado el sospechoso previamente
desde quito nuestro corresponsal Gustavo
Ortega nos detallaba Quién era María
Belén Bernal y la relevancia de su caso
y María Belén Bernal era una abogada 34
años que fue encontrada muerta luego de
haber sido
denunciada como desaparecida había sido
el presidente de la república quien dio
la noticia de su fallecimiento y esto
sucede luego que habría ingresado a la
escuela superior de la policía María
Belén bernalda es un niño de 13 años de
edad ella Trabajaba en un bufete de
abogados con seis mujeres y básicamente
se enfocaba a casos en materia penal
Pero porque el caso genera tanta
reacción en la opinión pública bueno
básicamente porque María Belén Bernal
fue desaparecida de la escuela superior
de la policía fue ahí donde se le vio
por última vez para ir a visitar a su
esposo a la 1:30 de la mañana
posteriormente fue su mamá la que puso
la denuncia de su desaparición y
posteriormente hay otros puntos que
también han llamado a la opinión pública
de la conmoción ha habido movilizaciones
por parte de movimientos feministas en
cuanto al manejo de este caso y en
Brasil la deforestación por incendios y
prácticas ilegales en la amazonía sigue
aumentando todo en la campaña electoral
para las elecciones de octubre un tema
sobre el que los dos principales
candidatos Yair bolsonaro y Lula da
Silva tienen posturas muy diferentes
Alba Santana tiene los detalles
la amazonía el mayor bosque tropical del
mundo está sufriendo pérdidas enormes en
agosto la deforestación aumentó en un
80% respecto al año pasado y los
incendios han batido
récords el mes de agosto Battle récord
como el más afectado por incendios en la
amazonía desde 2010
cifras que acusan un gran retroceso
medioambiental en el país en plena
campaña electoral a menos de un mes de
las elecciones presidenciales Los
Defensores ambientales culpan al
presidente Yair bolsonaro por acelerar
el deterioro del
bosquemos los últimos cuatro años
tuvimos un mandato extremadamente
antiambiental con el discurso y la
práctica fomentó El Avance de la
ilegalidad en la amazonía
Y es que desde que fue elegido en 2018
bolsonaro recortó la vigilancia
medioambiental y aumentó los permisos de
agricultura y minería comercial en el
Amazonas políticas que han dañado la
región clave para el combate de la
crisis ambiental algo que el presidente
ha negado ante el mundo
y la amazonía brasileña más del 80% de
la selva tropical permanece intacta al
contrario de lo que informan los medios
de comunicación nacionales e
internacionales
rebatidas por los medios y también por
el candidato favorito de las elecciones
de octubre el ex presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva que ha prometido una
protección más estricta de la amazonía
con mayores controles para frenar las
prácticas ilegales y más empleos para
desempeñar estas tareas
pondremos el tema del clima como
prioridad máxima lo que significa que no
habrá términos medios la
grandeforestación y los incendios
amenazan el delicado ecosistema del
conocido como pulmón del mundo un
problema que requiere de intervención
gubernamental
en el marco de una nueva audiencia en la
causa en su contra por presunta
corrupción en la adjudicación de Obras
Públicas la vicepresidenta de Argentina
Cristina Fernández defendió su inocencia
y además compartió sus sospechas sobre
los autores intelectuales del intento de
asesinato que sufrió la líder aseguró
que quien es la atacaron no fueron los
que planearon el magnicidio en la banda
de autores materiales lo tengo
clarísimos eso nadie puede pensar que
esa banda planificó ideó La autoría
intelectual de lo que me hicieron en
Cuba los ciudadanos están preparando
para votar Este domingo en un referendo
en el que deberán elegir si aprueban o
rechazan el nuevo código de las familias
la propuesta incluye medidas
progresistas como la adopción entre las
parejas del mismo sexo o la gestación
subrogada y legalizar el matrimonio
igualitario lo que convertiría al país
en el noveno de América Latina en
implementar esta medida sin embargo para
salir adelante la consulta debería ganar
con más del 50% en una nación marcada
por la fuerte presencia de la iglesia
pasamos a Canadá los habitantes de Nueva
Escocia se preparan ante la llegada del
huracán Fiona que se espera toque tierra
este sábado por la mañana en la capital
halifax su residente se apresuraron a
abastecerse de víveres y gasolina ya que
según las autoridades meteorológicas
esta amenaza con convertirse en una de
las tormentas más severas en la historia
de Canadá fionadas azotó con fuerza
varias islas del Caribe como Bermudas y
Puerto Rico
varias ciudades de América Latina fueron
el escenario de las manifestaciones del
movimiento frailes for Future que busca
crear conciencia sobre los efectos del
cambio climático en Chile activistas de
la ciudad costera de Valparaíso
marcharon hacia el congreso nacional
entonando arengas y en las que pedían el
derecho al agua en Buenos Aires
Argentina manifestantes plantaron un
árbol y criticaron los proyectos
energéticos del gobierno un ambiente
similar se vivió en Ciudad de México
decenas de personas llegaron hasta el
Palacio Nacional con pancartas que
exigían la protección del medio ambiente
mientras que ese eran similares se
vieron en muchas ciudades del mundo
en un contexto de colapso climático
ecológico inminente que todos los
científicos científicas lo están
diciendo el país sigue apostando a sacar
más petróleos el caso de petroleras en
el mar a seguir impulsando más la mega
minería que sabemos que es altamente
contaminante más beneficios para vaca
muerta más beneficios para la
agronegocio Así que los informativos 24
Gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]